alors c'est un honneur de parler de 20
ans pays vineux et je voudrais ce soir
vous convaincre que le vin est un
monument un monument offert à nos sens
et que les briques de ce monument ce
sont les tanins effectivement dans le
vin qu'ils soient rouges où qu'ils
soient blancs il y à des tanins et c'est
1 1 c'est eux qui vont construire
l'interaction des vins avec nos sens
d'abord le premier sens c'est celui de
la vue le vin c'est avant tout une robe
c'est une couleur un aspect qui doit
beaucoup aux tanins qui doit beaucoup à
des tanins colorer les vins rouges sont
colorés par des tanins qu'on appelle les
autant les anthocyanes vous les
connaissez parce que c'est ce qu'ils
colorent aussi les fleurs et puis ça
colore aussi pas mal de fruits avec des
tons qui vont du rouge ou bleu violet
selon l'acidité et les métaux qui sont
présents aux côtés de ses tanins mais
les vins blancs qui ne sont pas blancs
vous avez remarqué qu'ils sont en fait
vers jona jaune
eh bien ils sont également coloré par
des tanins les flavonoïdes et les et la
quercétine et les vins blancs doivent
aussi leur couleur à ses tanins une
couleur que là encore vous connaissez de
tout un tas de fleurs et tout un tas de
fruits qui sont également coloré par les
flavonoïdes ses couleurs du vin remonte
en fait aux couleurs bien sûr du raisin
qui peut lui même être noir rouge ou
blanc dans un raisin blanc ya que des
flavonoïdes et de la quercétine de la
chaire jusqu'à la peau dans un raisin
rouge la couleur rouge les anthocyanes
sont dans la peau seulement la chair est
blanche et là vous commencez à deviner
comment faire un vin rouge ou un vin
blanc
si vous pressez rapidement un raisin qui
soit rouge ou blanc de toute façon il va
vous donner d'un jus clair jus clair et
jaune ça vous donnera un vin blanc oui à
des vins blancs qui sont faits avec du
raisin rouge les champagnes par exemple
sont souvent faits avec du pinot noir
si par contre avant de presser vous
laissez macérer la peau d'un raisin
rouge vous à les extraire la couleur est
d'ailleurs pas que la couleur mais tout
un tout tout un tas d'autres tana qui
vont faire le reste l'histoire mais ne
nous embrouille on pas déjà pour la
couleur il ya des variantes qui sont
possibles il ya des variantes vous
pouvez faire tremper votre peau pas trop
longtemps et là vous allez obtenir tout
le dégradé qui va d'un vin gris à un vin
se monnaie à un vin rosé à un clairet ça
c'est la galaxie des rosés et puis il ya
aussi une solution qui est peu connue
bien qu'elle soit vraiment la façon
ancienne de faire les vins à partir de
raisins blancs c'est de faire tremper la
peau du raisin blanc et quand on a fait
tremper on extrait quand même des
composés qui sont légèrement beige je
rangeais on obtient 20 quelle couleur un
peu plus soutenu c'est les fameux vin
orange a dégusté si vous ne connaissez
pas ça revient à la mode comme tout ce
qui est à la mode c'est un peu cher mais
l'état n'a qu'est ce que c'est que les
tanneries parce que depuis tout à
l'heure on parle de tana mais qui sont
ces tanins
les tanins ont la caractéristique
d'avoir dans leurs formules chimiques et
là vous en avez quelques unes
quelques-unes parmi les 9000 tanins
qu'on connaît ils ont la caractéristique
d'avoir une ou plusieurs fois dans leurs
formules chimiques un groupement qu'on
appelle un groupement phénol c'est à
dire quelque chose qui est fait à partir
d'un cycle base et nick cette espèce de
cycle à cet expert l'hexagone et une
fonction alcool et gaza une ou plusieurs
fois et c'est ça qu'on appelle les
tanins général est justement le cycle
d'un scénic absorbe les longueurs d'onde
de la lumière qui nous entourent mais
pas toutes
et donc selon ce qui entoure le phénol
et bien il absorbe telle ou telle
longueur d'onde et donc il est jaune
rouge bleu ou d'ailleurs parfois
incolore ont ces cas-là il absorbe uv
mais c'est tout alors c'est 1 1 ils ont
une autre caractéristique c'est qu'ils
portent donc des phénols essais phénol
peuvent réagir avec l'oxygène
on dit que c'est une oxydation en fait
pour donner dès qu'ils donnent et ça en
termes de couleurs c'est important parce
que autant les phénols les tanins et
leur fénelon un peu des couleurs bien
précises autant les pilotes sont brunes
et ça ça vous explique qu'avec le temps
et l'oxydation des tanins vous allez
petit à petit avoir un vieillissement
qui va faire tourner votre vin a une
couleur un petit peu brune le vin rouge
tuiles puis bruni le vin blanc d'or puis
bruni à la fin à 25 ans tu 9 quelle que
soit sa couleur les bruns comme à madère
par exemple qui est très oxydé dès le
départ et qui est brun ça nous explique
donc pas mal de couleurs et ça explique
notamment cette couleur dorée qu'on les
vins botrytis et alors les vins botrytis
et des vins qui sont faits avec des
raisins récoltés un tout petit peu tard
en saison qui sont attaqués par un
champignon le botrytis ce qu'on appelle
la pourriture noble quand ça tacle et
les raisins c'est une pointure noble et
ce champignon se botrytis
da il n'aime pas trop les tanins je vous
tiens les tanins s'est décomposé défense
des plantes c'est des choses qui les
aident à se défendre c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça qu'on a beaucoup dans la peau du
fruit qui sont en quelque sorte ses
frontières extérieures et la chose la
stratégie de botrytis pour se
débarrasser de ses tanins qui enquiquine
c'est de les hawks idée d'où le
brunissement des fruits et d'où le fait
que le vin qu'on va tirer sera d'emblée
un peu plus avancés en couleurs parce
que c'est flavonoïdes ça car c'est in
auront été plus oxydé il sera doré voilà
pour la couleur et que cette couleur
elle est construite par des tanins
mais il ne s'arrête pas là car va pas
faire que on va pas faire que regarder
ce va enfin vous six mois non on va voir
le sentir ça c'est l'odeur c'est le son
appel techniquement le nez une seule
faction que je vais appeler direct vous
allez voir pourquoi tout à l'heure on va
revenir à l'odeur est dans cette odeur
les tanins sont présents ils font partie
des molécules qui permette l'odeur car
par essence les tanins sont pris d'une
hésitation leur cycle aromatiques le
cycle pandémique dont je vous parlais
n'aime pas trop être dans l'eau il a
plutôt envie de passer dans l'air la
fonction alcool elle est bien retenue
dans l'eau alors il saisit entre les
deux
partie d'entre eux qui se volatilisent
et il contribue aussi aux arômes
d'ailleurs quand ils s'oxydent il donne
dès qu'ils donnent des dérivés qui sont
beaucoup moins à l'aise dans l'eau
globalement et qui sont plus volatils et
ça c'est important parce que dans le
vieillissement du vin vous transformer
des tanins assez soluble en dérivés qui
nonick qui sont beaucoup insoluble qui
donc passe plus dans l'air et dégagent
plus d'arômes ça explique aussi les
pratiques finale quand on ouvre le vin
on le carafon laisse s'oxyder un petit
peu dans certains cas où on le met dans
un verre à pied qui va permettre de
l'agité légèrement alors ça augmente la
surface des changes avec l'air et donc
ça dégage un nez que vous allez devoir
deviner mais ça oxydes aussi les tanins
et ça provoque la formation de ses
formes cliniques qui vont passer dans
l'air et amplifier l'odeur
d'ailleurs le bouchon qui sert à boucher
la bouteille est légèrement perméables à
l'oxygène alors montré très légèrement
un s'agit pas de transformer notre vin
vinaigre mais il laisse pas c'est
l'oxygène sans laisser trop sortir l'eau
et l'alcool du vin le bouchon
arrêtons-nous de seconde sur le bouchon
au delà de son rôle pourtant être une
très légère oxydation qui matures les
arômes du vin il effets d'une molécule
qui s'appelle la super inc est une
molécule imperméable qu'on trouve dans
la collec' horse de tous les arbres
c'est une sorte d' imperméabilisant qui
empêche que les serbes ne s'évapore
directement et c'est imperméabilisant le
récupère pour faire des bouchons et la
subéraie ne vous savez c'est un tanin
alors cet internat de très grosses
tailles donc il va pas passer dans le
vin bien sûr il n'est pas soluble dans
le vin mais il nous joue des tours
parfois car si jamais cette se tanne un
fait subir in est abîmée endommagé
chimiquement il peut donner des dérivés
chlorés comme le chlore à n'isolent qui
donne le fameux arômes de bouchons dit
le goût de bouchon en fait c'est surtout
un arôme on va y revenir le goût de
bouchon c'est encore une histoire de
tanins c'est pas forcément ce qu'on
souhaite
mais ça nous rappelle que les tanins
sont très présents dans l'odeur l'odeur
mais aussi le goût oui parce que c'est
bien de flairer de regarder son vin mais
on en arrive au moment essentiel c'est
celui de
goûtez le goût c'est essentiellement
pour simplifier la mer le salé le sucré
l'acide il ya tout ça là dedans il ya
toutes ces notes même si la mère est pas
forcément très prononcé et en fait dans
ses notes l'a bien l'état n'a contribué
à deux choses ils peuvent donner des
impressions sucre et des impressions et
surtout surtout ils font l'amertume du
vin une amertume à laquelle on est
souvent habitués qu'on ne repèrent plus
mais effectivement les tanins sont amers
alors arrêtons nous deux secondes sur
cette amertume
ces molécules que vous voyez là sont pas
très bonnes pour la santé en grande
quantité rien à voir avec les quantités
du 20 mai ce sont des molécules à la
base je vous le disais par lesquels les
plantes se défendent ces des molécules
qui d'ailleurs était un petit peu
désagréable au botrytis tout à l'heure
et dans notre évolution nous avons été
sélectionnés pour percevoir l'amertume
d'aitana de façon atteint en moi j'ai
trop ce que c'est vraiment pas bon pour
la santé ça abîme le fois ça abîme les
reins si on en mange trop et donc il
nous reste sept détection à merde et
anna ils font l'amertume du goût des
vins ça c'est le goût à proprement
parler et qui nous rappelle qu' il ne
fait pas bon ben j'ai tous les tanins
rassurez vous dans le vin il n'y a pas
d'excès de tanin mais il ya assez de
tanin pour qu'il contribue un touché en
bouche alors le toucher en bouche c'est
un petit peu bizarre mais je suis sûr
vous le connaissez sous un autre nous
c'est l'astringence vous savez quand on
goûte un vin
en bouche il a une épaisseur une
présence et peut avoir au passage
dégager une impression velouté parfois
plus rappeuse parfois même ça laisse une
impression de sable dans la bouche ça
c'est l'astringence leur à peu du vin
qui est plus ou moins prononcées qui va
de l'agréable ont parfois désagréable
c'est quelque chose qu'on doit aux
tanins vous avez découvert quelque chose
sur vous que vous n'avez peut-être pas
aimé entendre vous êtes rugueux votre
bouche a eu vous donne une impression de
douceur de l'iss qui est tout à fait
illusoire
c'est dû à des protéines qui sont dans
la salive et qui lubrifie votre bouche
lorsque les tanins arrive dans la bouche
ils ont tendance à interagir avec les
protéines et à faire des espèces damas
qui empêche ces protéines d'agir et du
coup vous sentez votre bouche alors vous
n'avez pas la chance d'avoir un verre de
vin mais vous allez voir une
compensation je vous propose de mettre
votre langue
le bout de votre langue sur votre palais
c'est assez lisse maintenant avec le
bout de votre langue vous aller frotter
très fort pour expulser pour nettoyer
tout le lubrifiant ali frotter fort avec
votre langue là on voit qu'il frotte pas
frotter il faudrait maintenant tu as tes
votre palais ils purent à peu un il est
beaucoup plus râpeux avis vous avez
enlevé le lubrifiant
alors cette astringence elle est plus ou
moins prononcés selon le type de tana
selon leur concentration et elle va
effectivement vous donner en bouche
une impression qui est mécanique car
cette impression si vous mettez votre
langue sur votre palais govou la bougez
pas vous pouvez sentir si votre palais
et rugueux au lit ce nom le propre du
toucher c'est qu'il demande un mouvement
pourrait prouver si je mets mon doigt
sur cette table je sais pas si fait ça
sur le le fauteuil par exemple je ne
sais pas si c'est lisse ou non il faut
que je bouge pour savoir que c'est lisse
ou que c'est rugueux en d'autres termes
ce qui se passe dans votre bouche c'est
la même chose quand vous bougez pas vous
pouvez pas sentir l'astringence
l'astringence elle se sent quand votre
eng bouge d'ailleurs votre palais vous
l'avez senti en le t'attend avec la
langue est parlée sans la langue
immobile dessus c'est vraiment à toucher
avec la langue et ça explique que
souvent les spécialistes aiment bien
mâcher le vin sans bouger les jouets la
lampe pour justement bien exhaler
quelles sensations mécaniques et l douce
ou désagréable ils obtiennent mâché
votre vin c'est le toucher et vous savez
que les vins qui ont séjourné en fûts
sont souvent beaucoup plus astringent en
bouche que ceux qui ne sont pas dépassés
en fut alors il ya plusieurs raisons à
ça la première c'est que dans le bois du
fus dans le bois il ya des tanins et
dans le bois du fus vous allez retrouver
un certain nombre de ses tanins si les
fûts sont assez jeunes il libère des
tanins qui vont aller dans le vin mais
il ya mieux
le bois c'est dur pourquoi est-ce que
c'est dur c'est parce que ça s'est
imprégné d'une molécule durcissante
qu'on appelle la lignine et la lignine
si vous regardez sa formule
alors cette molécule énorme là y en a qu
un bout vous repérez plein de phénol
c'est encore un tanin est un agent alors
ils risquent pas de passer dans le vin
vous allez me dire avec cette taille là
oui mais quand on prépare les fûts on se
livre à une opération qu'on appelle le
bourrinage pas si vous connaissez le
bourrinage ça consiste à allumer un feu
au coeur du fus un feu très fort et
selon la commande du vigneron de faire
durer ce feu plus ou moins longtemps ce
feu va casser par la chaleur la molécule
de lignine en petits morceaux qui eux
sont des tanins de suffisamment petite
taille pour passer dans le vin et donc
vous allez aussi avoir des tanins qui
viennent de la lignine c'est à dire de
ce qui fait que le bois et bois de ce
qui fait que le bois est dur alors c'est
un allah selon la chauffe comme on dit
c'est à dire sur le degré et la durée du
chauffage imposé c'est un allah vont
être soit légèrement vanille et si on a
juste un peu chauffé
soit on va trouver les fameuses notes
empyreumatiques les notes de pain grillé
de griller soit si on chauffe encore
plus on va avoir des notes chocolatées
éventuellement des coûts de bois et
quand on chauffe trop ça nous donne un
bourbon par exemple les faits dans des
fûts extraits
chauffez je vous laisse goûter un
bourbon pour voir que finalement la
délicatesse de la chauffe ça vaut la
peine d'être étudiées
en tout cas nous en avons presque finie
mais n'ont pas encore tout à fait car il
nous reste encore à revenir sur l'odeur
l'odeur elle est encore là en bouche le
vin c'est plus que de l'amertume
c'est plus que du salé c'est plus que du
sucre et nous avons une zone de l'odorat
qui se trouve tout en haut du nez et
nous avons vu précédemment que nous
pouvions sentir le vin directement
faisant passer de l'ère prix sur le vert
vers le nez mais quand le vin est en
bouche et avec la chaleur de la bouche
en particulier à d'autres molécules qui
vont se dégager qui vont passer dans
l'ariège nez ou parle de rétro olfaction
et ça c'est l'essentiel des sensations
assez grande partie en tout cas des
sensations du vin en bouche et je vous
invite à faire l'opération prenant
n'importe quel aliment un peu sapide ou
météores ma bouche alors il va exhalé
par exemple de fraises et puis vous avez
vos bouches elle n'est en vous couchant
des vous empêchez les circulations d'air
entre la bouche et le nez et donc les
honneurs circulent plus et là vous allez
ressentir que votre aliment votre
fraises par exemple et acide votre
fraises à un tout petit peu d'amertume
elle a des talents d'ailleurs mais vous
n'allez pas du tout ressentir le goût de
fraise
rouvrez le nez vous rouvrez à la
circulation
l'arrière des et là vous allez retrouver
les arômes alors ça c'est vraiment
important 1
parce que cette rétro olfaction c'est
l'essentiel de la diversité aurait
prouvé en bouche sur n'importe quel
produit et elle diffère de l'olfaction
directe 1 1 sthers a pu une fois que
c'est dans la bouche ça dégage une odeur
très agréable et oui les conditions
physico chimiques sont pas les mêmes il
ya la salive
il ya la mastication il ya la chaleur et
ce qui s'échappe n'a rien à voir avec ce
qui s'échappait du munster sur la table
dieu merci
en plus dans la bouche il ya aussi de
l'air et wotan 1 vont continuer à voir
s'oxyder les fonctions phénol qu'ils
possèdent et a donné des dérivés qui
sont volatiles et donc on va avoir
encore plus de molécules qui vont passer
dans le nez d'ailleurs c'est la raison
d'une pratique peu ragoûtantes
à écouter le gros images il consiste à
faire passer de l'eau de l'air pardon
dans le vin alors ça en porte les arômes
bien sûr et ça va flatter la rétro
olfaction et s'oxygène le vin encore une
fois et dans la bouche oxygénation
finale dans la bouche
qui donc des livres c'est qu'ils donnent
qui sont plus volatils et aromatiques
c'est pas fini il y a encore une
dernière étape c'est que quand on a
débuté le 20 et qu'on souffle dans son
nez parce que c'est ce qu'il faut le
faire pour la rétro olfaction apprenez
souffler dans votre nez quand vous
mangez
il ya une longueur en bouche et une
persistance le vin n'est plus là mais
son odeur est resté pourquoi l'état n'at
s'accroche aux protéines vous vous
souvenez y en a qui s'accrochent aux
protéines de nos joues de nos gencives
et quand le vin est parti sont encore là
et du coup ils vont lentement être
libéré ensuite d'autant plus qui
s'oxydent et passe sous des formes
canoniques parce que là ils sont
présence de beaucoup d'air est remonté
dans l'ariège n'est faire persister le
plaisir du vin après le vin voilà
comment l'état d'un fonds jusqu'à la
mémoire du vin après qu'on l'ait avaler
vous avez donc vu que dans sévère il y à
des tanins et j'aurai terminé avec un
problème épineux celui de l'accord des
poissons et des vins vous savez que sur
les poissons beaucoup de vin rouge
notamment sont pas très agréables
ça donne un goût métallique alors ce
goût métallique est très intéressant
c'est pas vraiment le goût de métal
c'est le goût de quelque chose qui lie
au métal les tanins entraîne du fer et
du ferghana dans la tuyauterie en cave y
en a un peu partout et se faire qui est
entraînée par les tanins et d'autant
plus entraînés qu'il ya beaucoup de
tanins il réagit avec les acides gras
insaturés des aliments pour donner des
dérivés qui ont cette odeur métallique
et désagréable alors évidemment quand
vous prenez un poisson vous avez
beaucoup d'acides gras saturés on vous
dit même que c'est bon pour la santé à
cause de ça et si vous mettez un vin
très riche en tanins comme les uns rouge
puisqu'il a macéré avec la peau et qui
l'a extrait de la peau un certain nombre
d'arômes et bien quand vous utilisez un
rouge et bien vous dégagez cet arôme si
vous prenez un poisson qui est peu riche
en acides gras comme un ton vous pourrez
aller jusqu'au vin rouge
mais si vous avez un poisson très riche
en acides gras comme une sardine un
maquereau oublier le vin se sera jamais
parfait
si en revanche le poisson n'est pas trop
riches en acides gras tout en ayant
quand même essayer le blanc un blanc ça
à 5 à 10 fois moins de terrain qu'un
rouge en gros et donc ça aussi beaucoup
moins de fer et un blanc ça peut passer
sur le poisson celui là par exemple vu
odeurs touché goût et vu tous les sens
sont convoqués dans une dégustation et
pour le coup il y en a qu'un de sens
qu'ils soient pas convoqués
c'est celui de louise mais c'est sans
doute pour ça
contrainte c'est pour compenser ce léger
manque auquel les tanins n'apporte pas
grand chose et ça il va falloir le
continuer à table
car quand vous allez mettre des aliments
dans la bouche cependant que le vin
évolué puisqu'il est dans le vert
ou que la bouteille est ouverte ces
sensations vont se trouver changée
renouveler différentes
il faut continuer la dégustation à table
il est complètement vain de déguster
seulement le vin sans aliments la
dégustation continue pendant tout le
repas l'attention à l'évolution de la
couleur la tension à l'évolution de la
rom attention à l'évolution du goût la
tension à l'évolution de la persistance
c'est quelque chose que vous devez
pratiquer tout au long du repas
incessamment buvez - percevait plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]